vous vous êtes contre la vaccination
pour tous la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui aussi on est en train de
parler de la vaccination antique vide
oui d'accord
oui bien sûr parle de la vaccination
demolition pas la wii ne se rapportant
pas ce que tous les amalgames gens j'en
ai vu en les amalgames et anti vhc
l'assuré tismée consommer c'est vrai non
mais c'est vrai alors on garde la
déclinaison j'en peux plus enfin
j'aimerais qu'on ait la vie de du
docteur françois fraysse merci d'être là
docteur je fais un maître une avis mais
diamétralement opposées sur 7 je le
savais mais voit sa vie' non seulement
il faut vacciner et vacciner tout le
monde et c'est une impérative nécessité
absolue
pourquoi pourquoi on sait actuellement
que l'épidémie ne peut s'arrêter que
lorsque et là je ne parle pas au niveau
du territoire national mais bien aux
l'échelle mondiale que lorsque le taux
de protection collective atteindra de
l'ordre de 80 à 90 pour cent soixante
dix au départ sur les c'est fou premier
c'est fou c'est simplement vous arrêtez
de le déballer sur monsieur j'ai passé
quinze secondes alors vous a laissé
parler en prix alimentaires je vous le
permet je ne vous permets pas parce
qu'elle a vécu un exercice qui ne vous
permet pas forcément vous la vôtre
arrêté ne le connaissez pas on arrête
condéon le on laisse parler les gens
monsieur fraize oui donc on sait avec
les variants probablement l'immunité
collective droite est plus importante
donc la seule manière d'atteindre
l'immunité collective c'est bien
l'obligation vaccinale art en france au
jour d'aujourd'hui 60% à 65% peut-être
et se dit favorable à la vaccination
quelque chose je ferai ce que j'entends
ce que vous dites sur le vaccin et sur
l'immunité collective tout le monde est
un peu d'accord le preneur au mit à
danser devant après après les questions
que se posent les français voilà les
questions que se posent les gens pour ce
grave est celle qui se dit est ce que je
me fais vacciner et j'entends plein de
choses en ayant peur d'avoir un truc
avec le vaccin ou bien est-ce que je me
fais pas vacciner
pour l'instant ça se passe bien j'ai eu
je les ai eus
j'ai déjà vu une première fois lakovic
et pas été trop malade ou bien je l' ai
pas encore eu voilà et je suis passe
entre les gouttes
est-ce que je vais prendre un risque de
me faire vacciner au risque d'avoir
peut-être autre chose et c'est la
question que se posent les gens tout est
telle que le format militer vêtements ce
qu'ils font ces mêmes décisions et fait
un calcul le tournoi habilité à donner à
quelqu'un de probabilités actuellement
aujourd'hui quelque temps mais je suis
bien sûr déçu après sa balade aux faits
et à madame moi je préfère docteur du
diable juste monsieur fraize quelqu'un
qui est en bonne santé aujourd'hui
christie pour l'instant ça se passe bien
on lui propose de vaccins au départ on
m'avait proposé où je crois je vous dis
là je me fais l'avocat des dogues je
reprend l'historique on lui a proposé au
départ le vaccin astrazeneca prend lundi
alan l'astra zeneca attention finalement
c'est que pour les personnes de plus de
55 ans donc le mec a fait peut-être la
première dose de vaccin c'est votre cas
d'ailleurs géraldine vous avez moins de
25 ans il se dit bon il jardinait encore
bonne santé elle a fait la première dose
et se dit bon maintenant qu'est-ce que
je vais faire déjà je vais devoir
changer de vaccins bon le mec il dit
qu'est ce que je fais est ce que je
prends le risque de me faire vacciner
ou bien est ce que j'essaie de rester
comme je suis 2 d'essayer de prendre les
précautions voilà de garder les
distances de sécurité
voilà deux d'être assez loin des gens de
ne pas faire non plus le foot pas voilà
et se dira peut-être je vais passer
entre les gouttes et peut-être que voilà
je n'aurais pas je prendrai aucun risque
et on va pas m'affecter peut-être ce
vaccin qui me semble dangereux si
j'entends certaines personnes je fais
l'avocat qu'est ce qu'on ait des gens
dans les stades ne pas aller au concert
ne pas aller au cinéma depuis l eta mais
n'ont même pas unis ils ont libéré tout
ça sans vaccin ils sont en conflit
il fait beaucoup de sens elles ont
dégagé le pass annie terre le 1er disque
est extrêmement contraignant il a
disparu du coma